I thought I had my whole life planned
but now I'm here open to the adventure
I'm open to having a connection with
another younger man I hope I'm really
gonna find love TLC's newest reality
dating show MILF Manor has officially
made its highly anticipated debut
featuring eight middle-aged women and
eight younger men looking for love yes
fans can't believe the twist in episode
one
oh
that's my mom right there
you can hear this oh my God I just
thought straight to possessed eyes and
just stay there for a couple of seconds
and say what is this
I am really confused right now what is
really happening here yep though MILFs
we're shocked to learn that the pool of
men they would be dating from includes
each other's Sons there is no shortage
of drama with couples forming quick and
no surprise some women are already
disapproving of their son's choices
including 48 year old Pola you see his
body language though look at it no
whether she likes it or not I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to take my man home I
like to win hey Mom no I can't episode
one ends with Paula concerned about her
son Jose dating any wild women and in a
preview of what's to come this season it
looks like there's going to be no
shortage of jaw-dropping drama romance
and of course spirit I think your
feelings are hurt because she doesn't
like you then why she kissed me on the
beach telling me that she doesn't for me
I really feel that Kelly is like easy
and I don't like that Kelly is
definitely on the prowl I'm gonna go in
there
whether she likes it or not Billy Billy
and I are turning up the heat she needs
to stop [ __ ] blocking him